amy is with us in Virginia
hi Amy welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hello hi welcome yeah I am calling
because my husband recently started
listening to your podcast and you know
came home you know want to make a plan
to get us out of debt we listen to the
Total Money Makeover on a road trip a
couple weeks ago and we've got a another
couple who want to jump in and do the
Financial Peace University class with us
so we're excited about that my question
is kind of twofold one we have a larger
family we have seven kids and I'm just
wondering what kind of advice you would
have one you know just for a large
family going through the program and
then also like how to really include our
kids and talk to them especially the
older ones like the teenagers you know
about what we're doing it and why we're
making all these changes to make it now
not easier I mean it's gonna be hard so
just working through those things with
the kids you know with rare exceptions
the large families that I know one of
the benefits of that is is that the kids
start that the kids very quickly
realized that the whole world is not
about them then they learned they learn
to sacrifice you know to get ahead
because and they learn to collaborate
and they learn to you know that it's not
all about thank goodness I mean very few
times do I hear somebody as seven kids
in their small brats
I mean most of them most of them are
working and they're doing chores and
they're helping and otherwise you
couldn't survive you know just just the
logistic of operating the household and
the laundry right and so that they
already know that you you know you serve
around the family and and so I would
guess that unless it's a rare family
that their attitudes are already pretty
good towards this kind of thing mm-hmm
and you're just telling them they'll
give them the Y you know dad and I've
done some of these things this this and
this wrong we're correcting that and we
got to dig out of the hole and
you know we got some work to do and and
the family is gonna you know just like
we do on everything else we're gonna
buckle down and do the work to win and I
would be shocked if your family based on
its size I think that family size is an
advantage in this case okay if you're
sitting there with one kid and that kids
a princess you know that might be hard
to talk that kid off the ledge you know
but but your kids are cooperative they
know how to collaborate for a greater
good I guess do they yeah I mean for the
most part versatile kids well they're
still kids they're not perfect I mean
but but you know that they take care of
each other and you know they help you
know the older ones help you take care
of some of the little ones sometimes
they watch each other and they got each
other's back at a different way there's
a different dynamic in our family that
size that's true and it's a positive
dynamic by and large except for the
times that you're ready to pull your
hair out I understand but but you know
what I'm saying I mean is there anything
like when I think about you know like
the baby step $1,000 I mean I think you
know I mean a thousand dollars can go
like in a second
you know with so many people what's your
household income so probably around 80
varies but nothing although and yeah if
you want to beef that up a little bit
that's fine but the point is it's
supposed to be a small amount that can
go in a second I mean if it was a single
27 year old $1,000 can is not enough to
cover a transmission going out mm-hmm
it's supposed to go in a second it's not
the point is that it is too small and
how much debt do you guys have I don't
know 50 and 60 I think not counting your
house
yeah I'm between 50 and 60,000 and
what's that on we did our remodel on our
house credit cards from you know stupid
and we have two cars one we just have a
few months left to pay on and then
another one that's smaller on that okay
all right
and so the bulk of it is credit cards on
the remodel yes okay
and making a tea how quick do you
anticipate paying off sixty honestly I
have no idea I mean I know it's going to
take a lot of sacrifice and my husband
works he does some freelance work and
when it's good it's good and then it's
not infilled
well you've got you just got a lot of
mouths to feed so that's going to that
it that does the reality of your
household slows it down a little bit but
it's still doable
I mean if you had you know one or two
kids you know I'm going to tell you to
pay off sixty in two years maximum it's
probably will take you three okay you
know so 20 a year out of your 80 but
that's still pretty deep sacrifice
uh-huh you know but I think that's
doable and so when you start laying the
goal out and then you turn it into like
a lot of things I'm guessing mom you
tell me but I'm guessing you turn a lot
of things into family goals you know and
we put it on the refrigerator and we go
we're gonna check this off and every
time we hit a certain level we're gonna
have a little party and you know
everybody's involved in everybody's
cheering everybody becomes cheerleaders
and so then what will happen is is it'll
slow the whining down and and you know
they start going hey there's the end of
it we see a light at the end of this
tunnel and then you know life's going to
be good then and it's gonna help with
college and it's going to help with just
quality of life around here and
everything else and and by the way it's
not optional we're doing it you know and
this is but again I think attitude wise
you are and at an advantage over the
typical household with a few teenagers
in it
attitude wise now there's there's
certainly people can have two kids and
they're good kids don't misunderstand I
had three kids they were good kids
they were cooperative and collaborative
too but that was because I they were
scared of me but you know but I mean I
think you guys are gonna be fine but you
just you and I would treat it like any
of the other tasks I mean getting ready
for church is a task at your house right
yeah you know what I'm saying yeah you
guys have to line them up like ducks or
they don't you don't get anything done
it's just everything is everything's the
the stress
and the the you know the time commitment
level and everything else for everything
you do is move when you're running a
family that size and that's fine it's
not a put-down I just think it's I think
it all works to your advantage because
you know how to organize the family
knows how to organize the family knows
how to serve each other the family knows
how to collaborate and those are all
positive things they're gonna move you
towards this goal I'm excited for you
very cool it's a neat question and let
me know how you guys are doing Amy if
you got any questions give me a yell
back if I can help as you go along the
journey hey you guys Rachael Cruz here
hope you are enjoying the Dave Ramsey
show and did you know that I have my
very own YouTube channel yes that's
right it's kind of better than the Dave
Ramsey channel don't tell them I said
that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget one of the best videos out there
you